this video is sponsored by rocket money
save more and spend less by easily
tracking your finances with rocket money
using the link in the description
Brandon was beginning to feel Stir Crazy
the novelty of being out in the woods
alone had already begun to wear off and
now he was just feeling anxious and
isolated he had only initially planned
on being out here for a few days and now
eight days in he wasn't even sure what
he was doing anymore the whole thing was
a desperate attempt to try to uncover
some ultimate Clarity and Truth in life
to discover the purpose of things and
find his true self wanting to be like
Henry David Thoreau or Christopher
McCandless he decided to go into the
woods and see what was left when
everything was distilled down but he
hadn't discovered anything
Brandon concluded that it was time to
pack the whole thing up he packed up his
camping equipment his tent his sleeping
bag his pillow his Lantern his small
stove and everything else he brought
with him and he began to make his way
back down the trail to the small town
several miles away where he had left his
car
his head hung lower going this direction
just after converging onto the main
trail Brandon noticed what looked like a
mid-sized group of hikers approaching
him in the distance
once he got close enough he gave the
group the obligatory hiker head nod and
smile with a hey how you doing before he
could even complete the gesture however
a woman toward the front of the group
stopped and said hey are you here for
the Southpaw Eco Village Farm project we
had some confusion about where to meet
just want to make sure we don't have any
stragglers nope not me Brandon said
shaking his head and scrunching his lips
a bit nope well never mind then have a
great hike the woman said thanks you too
Brandon responded continuing on his way
after a few steps Brennan stopped he
subtly turned his head back around
toward the group and stared at them for
a moment his mouth scrunching up even
tighter wait hold up he shouted back
toward the group the group stopped and
turned around Brandon half ran back up
to them
what is the Southpaw Eco Village Farm
project he asked hesitantly it's a
pervaculture-based Eco Village project
we're developing a small community
focused on restoring and sustaining
local ecosystems and agriculture our
site is just a few miles up the trail
the woman pointed in front of her the
same direction Brandon had come from
what some required to join Brandon asked
scratching the back of his head the
woman smiled well at the moment just the
ability to walk a few miles in that
direction a pioneering spirit and a
willingness to help
okay I'd like to join then wow okay
great come on in the woman said
gesturing toward the group
around an hour later Brandon and the
rest of the group arrived at the site
the same woman he initially spoke with
along with two other individuals briefly
showed Brandon around it was a large
plot of land with eight mid-sized cabins
several large white tents a scattering
of smaller tents makeshift
infrastructure and several open areas
for farming
throughout the rest of the day and the
several days that followed Brandon
worked with the community to help build
and maintain various infrastructural
systems prep and maintain crops allocate
resources clean and upkeep the property
and surrounding area and so on he spent
most of his days working walking the
nearby Trails reading and talking with
other community members many of which he
now considered friends the work was
fairly arduous but Brandon mostly
enjoyed his time
still however he hadn't uncovered any
sort of big Revelation about life for
himself he didn't feel any different no
Wilderness Bliss no true self no Clarity
of purpose
nothing
around two weeks in another group showed
up to join the community with them they
brought unsettling news there was a
potential missing person in the area who
had recently gotten lost while hiking
the details were minimal and since there
was no cell phone reception or internet
at the Village there was no way of
easily finding out any additional
information the new group however
informed everyone that a large search
was being conducted in the area by local
authorities and search and rescue and
that it was believed to be very time
sensitive
immediately the whole Community took on
the role of assisting in the search
for the rest of the day and night the
community split up and surveyed the
surrounding Woods several police
officers Wilderness search and rescue
members and local volunteers also soon
showed up converging with the community
and providing those who they encountered
with more details and instructions
Brandon diligently and intensely
searched the surrounding Trails by
himself by the end of the night no one
found anyone
the next day the search continued
Brandon spent most of the early morning
searching the surrounding areas by
himself again at around noon he returned
to the Village to regroup and fill up on
water The Village was quiet there were
only a couple other community members a
couple individuals who appear to be
volunteers and two search and rescue
officers Brandon greeted the small group
as he collected a few items while he was
filling up his canteen one of the search
and rescue officers approached him
you're out there searching by yourself
the officer asked Brandon looked up yeah
but I'm staying on or near the trails
I'm pretty familiar with the area at
this point
okay well do you mind showing me and my
partner to the East Valley Trail we're
not as familiar with some of the newer
more obscure paths out here and that's
where we've been assigned next sure yeah
I was planning on heading in that
direction myself oh perfect
Brandon finished collecting his items
and then left back out into the woods
with the two officers I'm Alan by the
way the same officer said reaching out
and shaking Brandon's hand this is Jesse
Alan pointed at the other officer
Brandon shook Jesse's hand nice to meet
you guys I'm Brandon you look familiar
are you from southpaw Alan asked Brandon
no hmm weird they continued walking in
silence for a moment
what do you guys think the odds are that
we find them Brandon asked the officers
with a somber tone hmm hard to say at
this point it's not looking great three
days in with no real leads or prospect
it's never a good sign Jesse responded
and that's just from the time they've
been reported as missing we don't even
know how long it's actually been
Alan added yikes Brandon said yeah the
individual's parents say they haven't
been able to get a hold of them no one
has only lead we have is from a friend
who said the individual told them they
were going for a short hike out here
over the weekend but then they never
came back
Jesus Brandon said
yeah tough way to go out Jesse said
getting lost is a terrifying feeling but
the key is to not panic the more you
panic the more you try the more you
flail the more you force things the
worse it gets
the people who survive are the ones who
stay calm trust their intuition and stay
the course
[Music]
hmm Brandon mumbled
the three continued walking in silence
for a moment Brandon thought to himself
his face began contorting a bit
do you guys have a picture of the person
by chance
he asked
um yeah hold on Alan said as he began to
dig through one of his pockets he pulled
out a crumpled up piece of paper
unfolded it and handed it to Brandon
Brandon stared down at it have you seen
him Alan exclaimed
oh Brandon said his eyes wide his
face muscles loosening he looked back up
at the officers this is me Alan grabbed
the picture from Brandon and held it up
in front of Brandon's face comparing it
side by side the picture showed a young
clean-shaven male the officer put his
other hand up covering Brandon's beard
oh my God Allen said he grabbed his
radio we found him copy where was he a
voice responded he was helping us look
Alan said in a frustrated
self-deprecating tone what the voice
said back with confusion yeah he's with
us looking Allen explained he wasn't
even missing he just has a beard okay
copy great well I'll let everyone know
the voice on the radio concluded Alan
put his radio back down
Jesus I obviously had no idea Brandon
quickly said
kid your parents were worried sick
you ever heard of sending a text message
before you disappear into a commune
Jesse said with the sharpness in his
voice
yeah it's just not really the
relationship I have with them I guess I
didn't account for the no service part
Brandon said while rubbing the corner of
his brow
that's pretty funny huh Alan said after
a brief moment of silence
this whole time you thought you were
looking for someone else and so you were
looking for nobody
we found the person but the person was
never even missing they were part of the
search party the whole time
[Music]
in that moment it hit Brandon the
Revelation he had been looking for he
hadn't found anything because the logic
he had been using to look was all wrong
and it was in the strange inverted logic
of this bizarre situation that he
realized
the truth
an important part of having a life in
which we feel comfortable and capable of
exploring ourselves the world and so on
is having a healthy relationship with
one's finances so as to better have the
space and means to do so this video
sponsor rocket money is an all-in-one
Finance platform that makes it easy for
anyone to do just that managing lower
bills create budgets and smart savings
accounts monitor your credit score track
your net worth and more all in one place
like anything else without a clear road
map and the ability to track progress we
can easily lose sight and fall short of
our financial goals as someone who wants
to be very mindful about excessive
spending and develop savings for both
the near and long-term future rocket
money is perfect for setting up budgets
and tracking monthly expenses by
category with friendly reminders and
notifications as well as fantastic
visualizations of your spend to earn
ratio it's super easy to trim out the
financial fat and stay on track and
right within the app you can identify
unwanted forgotten subscriptions and
with a single tap rocket money will
cancel the subscription for you as you
improve your habits and grow your
savings and Investments over time rocket
money provides a clear holistic picture
of your net worth so you know exactly
where you are relative to the
destination of your financial goals
personal finances can be overwhelming on
your own but with rocket money it's
easier than ever to spend less and save
more go to rocketmoney.com pursuit of
Wonder or click the link in the
description to download and unlock even
more features with premium
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]